All is one of the biggest examples of the white savior trope
that I've seen in a while.
I hate to be the man that says I'm actually in the book,
but it doesn't even sound like you watch the movies either,
because in the first movie, at the very beginning,
the banay Jesserit make it very clear that the
creating a manipulative man under the guise of prophecy
to control the masses and rule the universe.
And it's a very self aware take on white saviorism
as also a very big critique on religion as a whole.
And spoiler if you haven't watched into
or if you haven't gone to the second half of the first book yet,
Chinese character really isn't all that against Paul,
leading to the premen to victory in the first place.
But I feel like it's a decision that the movies had to make
because people are becoming increasingly literate
when it comes comprehending these things.
And so if you didn't have one character that was super like,
obviously, no, this is how they continue to oppress us,
then everybody would have been leaving the theaters
thinking that organized religion
is the best thing that ever happened in history
and definitely didn't kill a bunch of people.